hello welcome to alternative use we're
very happy to have john stockwell with
us to discuss the implications of the
election to the presidency of George
Bush we'll be discussing that with John
today John is a peace activist a writer
a lecture an ex-cia agent and now a
prominent critic of the CIA who
currently is working on two books one on
the Vietnam War and another on the arms
race he's also been commissioned by
Oliver Stone to write a screenplay about
Central America and has been very busy
lecturing traveling around the country
and doing research since we last saw an
alternative years so welcome back John
it looks like our crew didn't show up so
I'm going to have to do camera camera
operator all three cameras as well as
participating this okay I'll jump in
whenever you feel like
vanna tiny talent right this is like the
oldest so John I think everyone is
concerned about what the election of
George Bush will mean for American
foreign and domestic policy and what a
bush presidency would be like we're
currently in the period a honeymoon
period where all the media are just
celebrating and being nice to them all
the politicians are snickering up to
them so let's give a critical
perspective on the Bush presidency that
we really haven't heard from our corrupt
mainstream media it's a tough one this
is of course the the calm before the
storm perhaps we have so little to go on
man's been a vice president politician
the responsible people say give him a
break let's wait and see right he does
my own position and then they say well
he is such a comedian but he could go
either way so to speak and they point
out that he was historically more
moderate than Reagan who has always had
a wild hair up his nose but I personally
am more of the school that I believe we
do know a lot about this man in fact we
know some things about him that are much
more significant and frightening than
what we knew about Ronald Reagan Ronald
Reagan was of course a committed concern
of who was known to have a slightly
defective mind so that's the area that
was the case and proved it and lived up
to and had some harsh policies when he
was governor of California but Bush the
CI directorship where he made these
contacts I worked for him you know I
witnessed personally his supervising CI
is covering up of illegal activity at
the end of the Angola operation and
early 1976 and he was actually fending
off the hostile Congress instead of
investigating and firing the
perpetrators of crimes he was fending
off the FBI in the Congress on at least
three or four major CI criminal
activities what were those activities
well one was the Angolan operation where
we had broken a number of laws much like
the Iran Contra and the Boland kind of
laws and then we had conspired to cover
up the breaking of the laws and I mean
literally we sat around the big oak
tables and discussed the law we went
down to the library and read up on the
law wait and then things like I remember
one session reminding the boss you know
don't contradict your separate last week
you said you know don't contradict
yourself this week if senator so-and-so
brings up a certain issue and this this
one he just plowed right into that one
and he was just telling the Senate you
know the Congress say I don't know I
wasn't here but I'm sure that I just
find it very difficult to believe but
we'll look into it early she'll just
give me some slack and he was reassuring
them and with you know him patting him
on the head they backed off and just
never got back to it he was also doing
the same thing about the assassination
of Patrice Lumumba which was being
investigated in that cycle and also the
Chilean operation of killing a you know
the track one track to alistair and
killing of Salvador Allende in Chile and
he was fending off investigation of that
on in the FBI stuff the Justice
Department was investigating some of the
mercenaries who had been involved in the
CIA's Angola program and they were
asking us specifically which ones had
worked for us and in what capacity
these and a young attorney showed up
from the general counsel's office
responding to Bush's supervision
policies and actually went through my
files and purged documents that he
thought would be legally incriminating
if we were subpoenaed you know if we
were investigated and all of that was a
thorough indication of Bush's policies
as I witnessed them beyond that we have
an incredible record that we will get
into in greater depth as we chat here
now of the connections that he picked up
when he was CI director so we have not
only Noriega but we have a dozen are
dozens of Noriega x' who have blackmail
control of this man now one would like
to give anyone the benefit of the doubt
and say hopefully they're going to be
more moderate but this man even wished
he to be more moderate on CI activities
would have an uphill fight because that
establishment has got so much dirt on
him and and I personally don't believe
he really has any desire or instincts to
withdraw from them I think he's I think
he sees a secret world that that goes
back to that Skull and Bones thing at
Yale that kind of secret elite
manipulation the Knights of Malta I
think he's I think psychologically he's
just deeply committed to a view of the
world where there's elite insiders who
are well above the normal laws of men
and God you look at see who's been the
heads of the CIA all these years and
it's been people who've been right up at
the at the top and intermingled
interlocked with the top people in the
American power structure it seems that
that's such an important part running an
intelligence service that the
establishment to people don't want any
Outsiders doing it what is the
implication then of having an ex CIA
director the President of the United
States this is the first time this has
ever happened that someone who is
deeply involved in intelligence
activities is actually the president
well it's a giant step towards the
national security state is what it is
it's it's a huge victory for the
national security establishment and
always remember that although it goes
far beyond the CIA but the CIA was
created in the National Security Act of
1947 and the national security
establishment has the CIA as one of the
inner chapters so to speak and have one
of its directors bought into the thing
totally and controlled by all of the
illegal activities that he's been privy
to and part of it it means just that
we've been watching and worrying and
people have been writing books for 15
years about the national security state
and this is a giant step in that
direction it's what it amounts that does
that mean that the CIA will have much
more influence in current policy than
they would have otherwise and the bush
has this mentality the sort of
conspiratorial covert action
interventionist view of the world that
these people have how do you think that
might translate practically into a
increased role for the CIA or crease
influencing you get into some nuances or
personalities if you will over all the
establishment that the CIA represents is
much stronger having Bush as as
president however it's difficult to
imagine the CI being more dominant and
active than it was under William Casey
for the simple reason that the man was
wild as he in a Wild Bill Casey and he
was running poorly thought out very
aggressive operations in every corner of
the world now Bush has decided to go
with William Webster a Webster is no say
the head of the sea as the head of the
CIA which means right yes which means
the head of the intelligence community
because the CI Director coordinates all
of the intelligence in the
bureaucracies Webster is no saint it's
not that you know that it makes you feel
reassured in fact he ran COINTELPRO to
the FBI under Reagan when they were
harassing the people who were supporting
that are lobbying against the Contras
and he but what what's the most ominous
thing about this man is that the
establishment exonerated him totally he
was permitted by the Congress by the
establishment by the Washington Post
media at the end of that thing when it
was exposed of taking the idiots out the
stupidity out the [ __ ] out of saying
well it's true I was director of the FBI
but I wasn't aware of any of these
activities and you know the Admiral ship
sinks and he's well I wouldn't wear it
had a hole in it sounds like the Ronald
Reagan deficient management style was
simply lying on Bush Bush used the same
out he sat in 17 meetings of National
Security Council in which they discussed
the in Iran Contra scandal and he says
he doesn't remember there ever having
talked about it
it was also another interesting thing
that he said when they asked about
Oliver North on one of the TV things he
said well they made two or three
mistakes the fact that it was all
illegal never even faze him it is making
it back to Webster though it's it's
interesting to note that two levels of
the intelligence or national security
establishment not the community are the
hard you know the professor the paid
professionals the on-duty professionals
but the community has spoken out at two
levels one at the Henry Kissinger level
they've gotten together and published a
paper in which they have spelled out
policies that that Bush should follow
which which speak pretty openly of
brutality towards a third world and then
at a level below that the Georgetown
professors where McFarlane went to work
after he left the White House were ray
Klein and others operate from or they
published these books the intelligence
requirements for the 80s and now they've
come out for the 90s these be Robert
Gates the former deputy director these
people have come out with publications
and statements and radio interviews and
one not vigorously protesting Webster as
CIA director because they say he is soft
on covert action he's not aggressive
enough yet we know that Bush is such a
believer in covert action that at least
it's unlikely there will be that much of
a curtailing of covert action well it
again we're getting into new wants it
they're going to run operations for sure
it's a question of how many and how wild
and then at a certain point you see it's
almost in the world's interest God God
knows this is a perverse kind of logic
but it's almost in the world's interest
to have a William Casey as opposed to
William Webster because Casey would go
so far that he would self-destruct right
he was truly a crazy wild and so these
things would be exposed and there would
be a reaction the Congress would clash
with him endlessly he would mining the
harbor's and lie about it
whereas Webster is muting it with the
Congress and building good relations and
by having a little bit better judgment
he may actually accomplish more in the
long run and it may be harder for us to
crack it open John could you go into
some more detail on this blackmail theme
of how Bush might be subject to
blackmail because of his involvement in
the CIA and in other activities during
the Reagan administration what would be
an example of this and how would such
blackmail work well let's go into the
most obvious case that we know of the
one that we have the best documented so
far and this is this black eagle thing
that was started in an 82 essentially in
a reversal of roles the CI is actually
created to give the White House and the
executive plausible deniability so they
can keep clean and if the
does something wrong they can you know
what we didn't know about it and they
can fire the CIA's director William
Casey reversed this policy and is
actually quite clever
in retrospect in iran-contra thing he
initiated the iran-contra thing but he
managed to have Ronald Reagan in the
White House take the heat for it he ran
it through Oliver North so it became a
political thing whereas the CIA was
clearly under the thumb of the Congress
or should have been or legally was but
he also this Black Eagle operation of
delivering arms to the to the Contras he
got George Bush to front for that to use
the vice president's office to front for
that and Bush was a very activist vice
president running this this this thing
they had on anti-terrorism supposedly
which is of course 1984 double speak for
you know running terrorist activities
smuggling arms and through that
operation they began to work through
Panama and the planes flying through
Panama and Noriega gave them access to
the air strips that they needed and
immediately began working the other end
of the line through the Medellin using
the same black eagle planes to fly drugs
up here into the United States and Bush
was his office was was fronting was
running this thing now obviously they
tried to maintain what I thought was a
very thin implausible deniability of
having Don Gregg running the thing right
out of George Bush's office with his
assistant what's his name Samuel Watson
and then Felix Rodriguez down in El
Salvador and then a network that went
throughout planes flying throughout
southern air transport involved their
own airplanes involved and and yet then
the only deniability was Greg saying
well I never told the vice president
about all of these things which is
utterly impossible it is not within the
realm of human with unless the person
were a Ronald Reagan and even then he
would have had to have known what what
Gregg was doing can you give us a little
background on Gregg
the fact that he and Bush had been
together in the CIA buddies for a long
time yeah Greg was a not an original I
think he came in to the CIA and 51 a
graduate of Williams College at the
height you know that was getting into
the the McCarthy era the height of
conservativism for the Korean War a very
very conservative era and and he joined
and had what you know was ultimately
tremendously successful career in fact I
thought that Bush would wind up
appointing him as a CI director and
instead he's gone with William Webster
the guy had to do with the
destabilization of Cuba in the 60s he
wound up in Vietnam in military region 3
in 1970 and that's the you know where I
was except I didn't overlap with him but
I got there just after he had left so
there were a lot of people were talking
about him and about Felix Rodriguez who
is one of his favored operatives and in
the height of the Phoenix program and
Shockley was his boss wasn't it and
Shaklee was the boss so usually the same
group moving in with George Bush then in
the basement of the White House my next
door to Oliver North - factly Shaklee
wasn't yeah - Shockley who had been
squeezed up but then but I was still in
operation and involved in a lot of these
well I'm sure the old boy thing works so
that he was in contact with them but
don't ever forget that these people
fight a lot there they are
are as bad as people in the peace
movement about 12 literally you remember
when Black Eagle eventually fell apart
and then the the enterprise kind of
became apart it Oliver North and Felix
Rodriguez were at each other's throats
and he's two very volatile unstable
dangerous men who couldn't get along you
remember the the incident that cited in
the foreign policy fall 88 issue
that black eagle was when the CIA
operatives it doesn't name them and
Israeli operatives drew their pistols on
each other this was 1985 85 and they
were about to start blasting each other
away and the senior head said everybody
cool it just you know slow down and
prevailed and got everybody put their
guns back and at the same time the
Pollard case was breaking and the US was
going to prosecute the powers in Israel
didn't appreciate that so it was fun for
Israel and against the United States and
Canon clarify something may argue
through with it but you know there's so
much of this material yeah I'm a bit
confused now Oliver North
office was next door to George Bush and
Donald Gregg's in the bottom of the
White House that I understand it now
were they working together or as I've
heard some people say they actually had
two separate arms running and drug
smuggling operations going or were they
separately coordinated well you know
they have done everything they could a
bus gate if you will and confuse the
issue North admitted that he was he met
with Bush on many occasions but he
minimised the cooperation the the way I
see it is there are a number of
different offices and people did have
different roles to play and there were
different power lines working and don't
ever forget that there is a just a norm
of every presidency since I've been
around anyway is a lot of intense
competitiveness
I mean people they're really ruthless
everybody's jockeying for position
endlessly inside the White House and the
vice president's office if he has any
power so so north was definitely part of
the same machinery he was definitely
cooperating with George Bush as as Bush
was cooperating with Casey but at the
same time North was definitely beating
his own drum and Tooting his own horn
and flying around the world
grandstanding and setting is they were
not what you know it was not a
disciplined unit like one CIA office
would be a lot
one Marine Division would be a one-one
of your Navy ships would be and these
are a lot of competing people who are in
the same ideology the same
administration and and moving in the
same direction
what's a naval in touch the way that the
Rolling Stone told this story in the
November 3rd essay on his dirty secrets
of George Bush the Black Eagle operation
that Bush Rodriguez and Gregg were
running was coming apart because of this
rupture with the Israelis and also
because they found out Noriega was
running so many drugs that this was
threatening the integrity of the
operation so north began this other
Enterprise literally called the
enterprise with Richard Secord and Hakim
and these people to bring arms down to
the countries but Secord had trouble
getting it off so that Felix Rodriguez
began another operation and once Secord
got his going they shut down the
operation with Rodriguez's Cuban friends
who lost a lot of money in this and very
angry and this began the tension between
Rodriguez and bush and the Secord north
group and eventually the tensions there
sort of exploded and Bush was the guy
supposedly trying to hold everything
together that when these other guys
North and Rodriguez were each other's
throats Bush was the guy that had to
smooth things over so again he played a
major role in carrying out these
operations according at least to these
this Rolling Stone story that seemed
fairly well documented no I I in Dorset
the way the way you describe it is the
way I have I have read it myself very
much that in fact the one the original
outfit they had built this giant
warehouse called the arms supermarket
and stocked it with arms which was
supposed to be bought by the Contras
with US taxpayers dollars of the private
enterprise dollars and and at the time
that that North pulled away from that
that Enterprise to start the enterprise
they had that thing stocked with 18
million dollars worth of arms now you
know arms is a cash for business and
this cash had to come from the Medellin
Colombian cocaine cartel so there was
drug money that they had been working
with that it stocked this warehouse
counting on selling the arms to the to
the enterprise small e to that and then
north did break away at the point where
he saw that thing apparently as getting
out of control as being too explosive
now it was not don't anyone
misunderstand that he was morally
troubled by working with people who were
smuggling drugs he had known for years
these people were smuggling drugs but as
you noted the volume of it was getting
so high that he saw an earthquake coming
and actually moved there also was
undoubtedly a part of his ego power play
power struggle at the level of him in
Rodriquez at the level perhaps of him
and a Gregg during this whole time
George Bush was supervisor he was
control of the drug anti-drug program in
the United States not just the
propaganda bit you know just say no but
great operand and very expensive
operation
to interdict drugs and to keep them from
coming into the United States so it was
a perfect circle not only from the
propaganda point of view because Bush
could be said to be the guy who is
keeping it from coming in but on in the
covert aspect he could make sure that
this stuff came in undetected and yet
none of these stories came out during
the election campaign when I left for
Europe on August 17 during the
Republican convention Dukakis was ten or
fifteen points ahead Bush had just
nominated Quayle chosen Quayle as vice
president that looked like it was going
to be a self-destruct operation and when
I came back a month later Bush was ten
points ahead what do you make of this
how do you analyze Bush's turning things
around and winning the presidency what
was involved in is well one just quick
observation is there
a false foot some false pulling in the
summer after the Democratic convention
the Democrats always look better they've
gotten a lot of publicity and then a
month later after the Republican
convention they have a surge back and so
it's sometime about the 1st of September
where the polls I think I forget the
figure but it's something like nine
times out of ten the one who is leading
on the 1st of September wins
so it's stabilized by the end of August
and in fact by the end of August Bush
was ahead again the quail thing was a
heavy hit a bush it one might call it a
major blunder but since he succeeded we
all reflected on that lot his choice of
quail as I see it was twofold he had to
pick someone who would make him look
like a giant and that was not easy to do
if he picked a Bob Dole for example
someone who knew knew more and had a
stronger personality he would have all
kinds of problems he also in my opinion
and this is an analysts opinion you know
this is not based on any hard quotes or
anything very subjective but he also had
to pick someone who was bought into the
iran-contra scandal and Quayle was he
was the senator from Indiana and
Indiana's the state that John hull you
know came from who was the man who had
the ranch in Costa Rica from which all
the drug smuggling in the arms you know
from the southern side of the contra
thing had been run and it turns out as
we dug up in August and found out it
this young man working for quail
introduced Hall to Oliver North
originally and that young man's name was
Robert Owens and so it was involved
Quayle Owens was working for quail
when he introduced John hull oh yes when
he introduced John Holt Oliver North and
gave them that whole op
shunned which evolved into the
enterprise and and the whole scandal
that's incredible the whole
interconnections all of it yes enter
could even quail I mean this is the
amazing what to go back this is a very
complicated thing but I think we can
sort it out
I don't think Bush dared to have someone
in office who was clean of the
iran-contra thing like dole who could
benefit from an impeachment so he needed
someone that would be tainted enough
with the iran-contra that they would be
forced to resign at the same time they
would be impeached with him who could
not possibly benefit from his
impeachment he needed to create a
situation correct himself where the
establishment couldn't shunt him aside
and put in a strong figure like door or
Howard Baker who would be very
acceptable to the public and to the
establishment right and that's that's
where I work well that's where Quayle
came and that Barbara Honegger who is
not the world's greatest analyst but she
certainly has a lot of fire and
imagination and she coined the phrase
that he was Quayle was Bush's
impeachment insurance who who is she
teller onager worked for the bush Reagan
campaign in 1980 and then quit and in a
volatile protest of their activities and
has made a crusade out of exposing the
October Surprise Minaj will get into
this and so this is one of the stories
that was covered over by the mainstream
media was her initial story well her
initial story was that the Reagan Bush
campaign William Casey the Reagan Bush
campaign had made a deal with the
Iranians to keep the Embassy hostage
through the elections and then another
76 days so that Carter wouldn't even get
credit for the release you know so that
Reagan would get the full credit for
their release and they were in fact
released two hours after he was sworn in
which was enough time for the word to
get back to Iran that he was in fact
president and then
you know they were the hostages were
released they were actually held at the
airport waiting for this confirmation
and then to go back to our other thing
we were working on here is why didn't
Dukakis take Bush's head off that stuff
which he could have got knows you can
see the television commercials are shows
in our interview five-minute segments
showing the Noriega Lincoln about black
eagle the whole stuff we had all of this
and we were definitely trying to feed it
to them and what what what we got back
from them was decision they Dukakis in
the Dukakis and we got inside we got we
got we got the movie cover up delivered
to them we got the movie the PBS
Frontline show guns drugs and the CI
delivered to them we got in to see them
some of the people inaud disorganized
group of scholars researching this thing
and we we got from them a resistance
they they they essentially and feedback
as one of the the senior Dukakis people
told Jim Driscoll who's in our community
with the Americas peace test and Nevada
that John stock pulls facts are all
screwed up and and I you know I
immediately what facts what is it
because I consider myself if not an
academic nevertheless of scholarly
things and so what facts because I want
to check them out if I am scrap I don't
you know I don't and they wouldn't give
us any details but they just rejected
the stuff out of hand now if you permit
me just very quickly to create a
scenario or give you my analysis what
happened and we note the scandal broke
or was broken by the establishment in
November of 86 iran-contra scandal and
it led to a dismantling of the Reagan
White House and then later they gave him
his credibility back with the INF
agreement now in the winter of 1987 the
the George Bush was written up by it by
every major columnist as being out of
business he was finished politically
they were saying this open
George will was writing columns that the
Republican Party was out the Democrats
were clearly going to win the next time
around and they were all writing that
George Bush could not survive the
iran-contra scandal and this is because
they including the conservative
columnist and the establishment press
had this material back then right and
they knew about george bush's
involvement in all of this stuff and the
scandal was breaking and they did not
believe that he could survive right by
the spring he had survived to the point
battling as I as I put it to stay out of
jail he had hung in there he didn't
resign or retire and they began to
wonder what the u.s. of people's
tolerance was of the scandal how much it
would stick then they engineered the
iran-contra hearings in the summer which
were carefully orchestrated by dannion
way the Democrat in cooperation with the
other Democrats Cohen and Mitchell for
example wrote the book men of zeal which
they profess to be an expose abide the
scenes but they do not in fact expose
it's a continuation of the cover-up they
do not for example discuss their
resistance at having of allowing the
Black Eagles stuff to be investigated
and they're their own resistance of
having the George Bush drug linkage
investigated so the committee drew a
line and said we won't investigate
beyond this line so they gave the nation
the appearance of an airing and they did
not in fact probe into the things that
would have led them into the impeachment
of George Bush and this had a catharsis
effect on the nation and then we get
into the the fall and then the winter of
88 and then the spring and there's still
a debate going on in public remember dan
Rather who tried to nail Bush I tried to
break this stuff in a CBS interview and
what happened was the establishment came
down on him and said no we know we're
not going to go after George Bush until
eventually in the summer of 88 when we
were once again trying to break this
Bush eventually was able to laugh at the
cameras at the Republican convention
because we had journalists I mean we
had found journalists who would ask the
questions who went up on national
television and said what about the
iran-contra thing and he just laughed at
him and said I'm not even going to
answer those questions anymore the
nation doesn't care about the
iran-contra scandal that is history I've
answered those questions forget it don't
ask me any more now in the meantime this
establishment this party that we have
the single party state this fraternity
that runs this country that has two
chapters a Republican and a Democrat one
a little bit more liberal than the other
one one more conservative representing
them the big business interest more
directly that's the Republicans in terms
of their interest that's the eighteen
but they always have the b-team that
they can run out a Jimmy Carter when
Richard Nixon makes the nation too angry
or the nation gets too riled at the
Vietnam War or something like that this
is where they produced Michael Dukakis
he's a team player to the establishment
in order to be accepted as a
presidential candidate he did homage to
the to the arms race he said eventually
that he would give humanitarian aid to
the Contras he would consider it he said
definitely he would give military aid to
El Salvador which means he bought into
all the principles of the covert secret
government of the covert operations of
the covert manipulation of the world he
was singing another song when he was
trying to get the Democratic nomination
that's right before his background was
progressive but he bought it they
screened him into the system they
groomed him into the system he was
advised that he could run but if he
would so what he was there is he if the
nation had clung had its outrage had
been sufficient over the iran-contra
scandal they had Dukakis standing by the
b-team to their interests and he would
give them some grief by spending some
money on housing and on medical
insurance for people and things like
that which is not their choice of the
way to invest the money they want to
invest it in missiles and things where
they make greater profits but he would
support the arms race and he would
support the CIA and the corporate
establishment the National Security
States activities but then they realized
they did
not have to go with the b-team the
people didn't care they didn't have to
give the nation a beat team so they went
ahead and went with the 18 which was
George Bush ie
they concluded eventually that they
could Teflon eyes Bush despite all of
this incredible activity and selling to
the nation and they did hmm why though
did Dukakis as the B team not go after
bush more aggressively because he's a
member of the team he's a member of the
fraternity why did Danny no way they had
they had Ronald Reagan and George Bush
by the short hairs
they could have impeached them and they
didn't because they couldn't impeach a
popular president like Reagan and Bush
without losing control the public trust
see this gets back into the Howards End
thesis that the American Revolution
occurred when the rich white people rich
white males over here wanted to take
power away from the same element in
England and they engineered a deal with
the people whereby they would give more
freedom to the people than they had
under the monarchy or the colony but
nevertheless the rich white males would
retain control and and this this dynamic
relationship we don't have a democracy
we do not even to this day a vote for
the president we vote for electors who
select the president in addition to
which this two-party system we've
evolved gives them further control
because even the selection of the
candidates it's done by about 50% vote a
popular vote through the primaries and
about 50% through the frozen delegates
of the Hart delegates of the
super-delegates who were party hacks who
control you know the party machinery
controlling ultimately who gets
nominated this is why Pat Schroeder gave
it a run and dropped out is because her
traveling and consulting with the
super-delegates the frozen delegates the
power structure of the party she was
told she would not be permitted to win
whatever happened you know in the
popular side of things
and then once that was decided you know
the money was not available to her now
this system as it can as it has
continued for 200 years is a tenuous
relationship in which the people who own
the country the people on the foot you
know who the Federal Reserve Board the
people who manage the money and and the
moneyed interest the strength of the
capitalist system these people know that
they're writing a potentially rebellious
horse and the American people whose
interests are not being fully served
myth has to be maintained to make this
thing run and it's a constant balance of
what do they have to give the people to
keep them onboard the system and at what
point are they going to lose the system
you read the history through Zen's eyes
of the United States or the grameen gum
book on the history of violence in the
United States and you see that every
time the people have become angry enough
the system has yielded to them the labor
struggles at the turn of the century for
example the Vietnam War in civil rights
days when blacks rose up in the country
with a massive boycott and it began to
really hurt the economic interests you
start out reading down the small
businesses in the ghettos and white
business while it wasn't Detroit and
Watts and 14th Street in Washington and
you know when that when a nation when
the system was breaking apart the
establishment yielded every time and the
system self-destructed the cynicism of
the Reagan years in which one of the
more dramatic transfers of wealth from
the poor to the rich occurred you know
was orchestrated by Ronald Reagan
through the arms race the two trillion
dollars on arms the mechanisms that he
set up for him that rigging of the taxes
where he could say taxes had been cut
when they had been redistributed to hurt
the middle class and poor more this
thing came to a head under the
iran-contra scandal and once again the
establishment was faced in the winter of
87 they were saying you know
we've hadded the people the people have
had it and we're going to have to give
them the democrats for a while and they
came up eventually with with what was to
them a brilliant the perfect candidate
was Dukakis who had a reputation of
being clean after the corruption of the
reagan years who had a reputation of
being somewhat of a populist as jimmy
carter did who could be sold as a
cleansing sort of as a here you know we
sympathize here you can have your
president for a while the truth is that
that Jimmy Carter had foisted upon him
the big Rosinski you know it was an
utter fastest in his policies to control
the national security decisions so
Carter's human rights stuff couldn't go
too far and he wound up setting in
motion the arms build-up that eventually
evolved into the Reagan arms buildup
which is the biggest peacetime buildup
in the history of the world biggest
buildup in the arms buildup in the
history of the world ever since he moved
into the bush camp and during this
county indeed and at and of course
that's part of the October the election
held hostage the the playboy article
brings that out very clearly is that
having put he doesn't get into there
having put a Carter in office to placate
the people after Nixon after Vietnam
after the civil rights struggle that
then gets into that but they're taking
it up at the time of at the end of the
Carter era era where two things had
happened one is the Federal Reserve
Board cooked the economy and so we had
runaway inflation which would scare
people you could feel it you could taste
it and the newspapers talked about it
every day and blamed it on Carter and
when when he doesn't control the stuff
the Federal Reserve Board does and then
the other thing was the national
security establishment went after him
with a passion
the CIA operatives cooperating with Bush
Reagan during the presidential campaign
of 1980 the Pentagon cooperating
MacFarlane their Marine officer working
in the State Department advising but
having committed himself to the bush
side all of these these tendrils go back
to the security establishment saying
okay we've given them Carter for four
years now let's get back to work and
they got they got Reagan in there to
summarize they got Reagan in there and
he eventually self-destructed our the
system self-destructed under his watch
they thought they were going to have to
give us Dukakis to placate the people
and then they found that the people
simply don't care enough the people
simply aren't vigilant enough of their
own interest to care enough about this
monumental corruption from George Bush
and and the people around him and they
were able to continue with the 18 in
office with George Bush to extend and
continue the policies of Ronald Reagan
to exploit the nation and to keep in
lockstep with the drug runners not to
mention the military machinery I thank
you that's an excellent analysis of how
the establishment would view the two
different candidates and why they would
then decide that they could pull behind
bush and go with what you call the 18
again
it still doesn't completely explain why
the B team that is Dukakis and the
Democrats didn't fight harder for the
president he didn't go after bush more
aggressively on this Noriega drugs
contra drugs the Iran arms deals the
whole relationships of Bush and Reagan
the ayatollahs why didn't Dukakis and
the Democrats use these issues to
probably win the election if they could
have publicized them it was the negative
campaign of Bush against Dukakis that
many people think helped win it for Bush
couldn't of Dukakis have done an honest-
campaign against bush telling the actual
truth about bush and why didn't I still
have trouble of course of course the
Reagan administration is the most
corrupt in the history of the country
they've had what almost 200 people
either indicted or in jail for
corruption and my administration and the
Democrats didn't go after this I
mentioned here
why well this again gets back to the
decision they made I mean we can only
cite what they did and then it speaks
for itself then anyway running this
committee
a Democrat you know made it a joint
thing and then the Democrats shut up and
let the Republicans use it as a forum to
advance the national security state the
CIA's activities the contra program
instead of exposing the corruption
that's where the decision was made
Dukakis is just another member of the
team whatever economic miracle
supposedly occurred in Massachusetts
under his governorship was done in great
part with defense expenditures he is
bought into the system he's a member of
the team with the establishment as as we
know as we've observed I remember
talking to les Kurtz about this when he
was developing the draft of his book the
the nuclear cage and we were talking
about the military-industrial the Iron
Triangle the military-industrial complex
the defense corporations the Pentagon
and the Congress and then we took it a
step further of course it includes the
media as everyone well knows the point
of alternative views is that the media
is owned literally by the same people
who owned that you know the Defense
corporations but then we took it a step
further it's not even a quadrangle it's
it's a pentad or pentagon because you
also have the universities the
educational system in which the defense
corporations and the Pentagon are
careful to invest heavily 70% of some of
these big universities budgets come from
from defense you know money so the
professor's are paid for the salaries
are paid for by the defense complex and
so they bought into the system so you
have that power structure and control
and that power structure determined not
to let the system be destroyed or be
weakened even at the price of their own
let me put it this way Jimmy Carter for
example he demonstrated this this what I
would call misdirected loyalty after the
1980 thing he did not go public and
protest the iran-contra deal he did not
protest it in October when he had these
reports coming in
because he didn't want to destroy the
system of which he was part to go back
to another era 1960
Richard Nixon lost to John Kennedy in a
very close election which turned in part
on on mayor Daly in Chicago counting
every grave in Chicago twice now this
scandal was known at the time Nixon
didn't mention it until God knows 20
years later he eventually said he
couldn't he couldn't make an issue out
it without destroying the credibility of
the presidential election process and he
wanted to have another shot at the
presidency which again if which he got
and became president if he had destroyed
or attacked the system if he had exposed
that scandal it would have destroyed
perhaps it wouldn't take all that much
to lead the American people to have a
big mental breakthrough and demand a
change in the system perhaps in the
direction of a parliamentary system
where we could at the time of an
iran-contra scandal there would be
forced a vote of confidence and Reagan
certainly would have been out and in in
December of 8086 he would have been out
this is my studies on the power
structure in the mass media this is the
main thing they try to keep from the
American public how the economic and
political system really works because
the Americans wouldn't like that at all
if they really they really knew saw how
scared the establishment dodged a bullet
how scared they got in the end the
Jackson run at the presidency this last
time because Jackson is the first
national prominent figure since I can
remember who has who has achieved
prominence and represents the interests
of the people pretty directly and the
the manipulations they had to go through
to keep him from getting a position of
of in fact power just to cite one
example of how far they will go we we
this this loose Association of exes from
the national security we were flying to
Iowa to do a hearing to try to force the
candidates to tell us their policies is
by at that point there were a lot of
candidates and on the plane the day we
went up there the New York Times had
big piece on where the poles put all the
candidates at that time in Iowa and it
had it had Simon I think was leading and
a big front-page article and and then a
long discussion Simon and Dukakis and
the others and when it and then you went
to page three for the bigger article the
details and it turns out Jesse Jackson
was running a very close second it was
sort of like 33 to 31 but his name was
not mentioned on the front page of the
New York Times or a time inside they
showed the polls but on the front page
they didn't want him to have the name
recognition well the times that all the
mainstream media pretty much did a
blackout on the excuse the metaphor on
the Jackson campaign until the Super
Tuesday primaries were he won and then
he became a head actually after the
Michigan primaries he was the
front-runner and then they had to give
some attention to Jackson and they tried
to make it negative and then Dukakis
regained the momentum in the
Pennsylvania New York primaries the
party's probably the only hope looking
back the party machinery shifted gears
at that time scared because Jackson was
leading and there was a chance that the
people would really get excited about
his thing and that 50% control asserted
itself the party machinery asserted
itself and Jackson was was pushed down
and Dukakis was run in instead they did
it by calling Jackson a radical they
said it's not racial we have no problem
with his skin color although there would
be some people in the South who wouldn't
vote for him but he's a radical meaning
he doesn't support the establishment and
they got that word out to the party too
you know to the party hacks throughout
the nation and the result is that
Jackson's and I've been wishing and
hoping but like what you said that
Jackson would split off and give us a
third party and with with the people
that I believe would follow him we might
be able to force onto the two-party
system a viable third party and then we
could you know throw our block of votes
to the right or the left depending on
who would give us the most real
concessions I don't think Jackson will
ever get these
sessions from the Democratic Party which
is where he's trying to notice the
election night I flipped on one channel
I think it was NBC and the analyst was
saying well the reason the caucus lost
was because Jackson spoke out for him
and then I immediately turned to the
next channel which was ABC and that
pendant was saying well the reason he
lost was because Jackson refused to
support it total none yes Jackson was
traveling all over the country literally
every day campaigning you know 10 things
a day he was doing or you know many and
this was followed up I saw it a big
Newsweek article analyzing the election
and it said well they were looking at
the prospects for the future and they
said the only thing the Democrats can do
is to go with people like Gary Robb who
are conservatives so the Democrats can
move to the right they said the worst
thing they could do would be go Jesse
Jackson because it would tear apart the
Democratic Party and destroy it every
election with these centrist liberals
like Mondale and Dukakis but you're
talking about the Democrats in there
another problem which Democrats had and
that is they went lockstep right along
with Reagan and Reaganomics and
providing money for the code trost
our arms bill absolutely see the arms
build-up for example the money the power
structure that keeps the Democrats in
office the ones that are in office the
this is Reaganomics paid off enormous
Lee for them now that you do get into a
lot of individual struggles and and
infighting and and you know the system
it isn't a monolithic it isn't the the
controllers of the country being in
lockstep not at all some of them
actually jump out of the windows of
their office buildings in New York
committing suicide on occasion it's
there's a lot of tugging and pulling but
nevertheless when the chips are down the
establishment will will not go for the
jugular vein their own jugular vein if
you will they will cooperate in a
cover-up Howard Baker you know going in
to straighten out the Reagan White House
there by perhaps forever abandoning his
shot at the presidency
NIC's and you know refusing to expose
the scandal Jimmy Carter refusing to
expose this and Dukakis decide to talk
is refusing to expose the scandal Lyndon
Johnson's behavior after they'd killed
John Kennedy the Warren Commission
cover-up you know let's get back to
business as usual let's calm the nation
down let's not take the the scab off the
wound you know and let the people see
let's let's paper it over and cover it
up put a bandage on it and get on with
business as usual well because of what's
at stake is the viability of the system
for them for them so to draw a
conclusion to wrap up our discussion
today it would seem that we really can't
expect from the Democrats or the media
any real exposures of the scandals and
corruption of the system any real
important efforts to change or reform or
transform the system there really
depends on the people that we're the
only active agents of change that it
depends on alternative media alternative
socially critical progressive
researchers to dig this dirt up that
this is sort of our obligation that if
change is going to happen it's not going
to come from the Democratic Party it's
not going to come from the media can
only come from the people so that our
obligation during the Bush years is to
be critical vigilant and militant and
trying to smoke out all of these
scandals and get rid of bush and force
the system to change that that's the
only way change comes in